el momento de conocer las principales
noticias en materia económica de américa
la dine del resto del mundo y por eso
nos acompaña por supuesto como siempre
nuestro compañero jorge hurtado jorge
muy buenas noches bueno comenzamos
hablando de una fecha muy esperada por
muchísimos el black friday llegó así de
santiago en esta fecha de inicio a la
temporada de compras navideñas que se
realiza en todo el mundo especialmente
en eeuu y europa donde se vive un
viernes negro atípico los minoristas han
reportado un aumento de ventas en los
últimos meses impulsado por la
reapertura de eeuu con un importante
porcentaje de su población vacunada esto
motivó a los compradores pero bajo una
dinámica y un contexto muy diferente a
los años anteriores los problemas de la
cadena de suministro mundial están
reduciendo los inventarios y haciendo
que los precios aumenten pese a esto los
estadounidenses aumentaron su gasto en
el mes pasado elevando las ventas
minoristas y dándole un impulso a la
economía las ventas minoristas crecieron
a una tasa ajustada por temporada de 17
por ciento en octubre respecto a
septiembre según datos del departamento
de comercio esto es un aumento respecto
al 0 8% regístrado al mes previo
conversamos sobre esto con josé guerrero
cusumano él es profesor de la escuela de
negocios de la universidad de georgetown
y le preguntamos por qué la gente compró
antes e incluso con mayor índice de
inflación
importante en eeuu los 10 años en que la
gente empezó a comprar para las fiestas
y navidades muchos meses antes era no
empezó a comprar en más que entre
octubre noviembre diciembre así que no
nos sorprenda a nosotros en este momento
que no haya tanta gente en los negocios
porque lo que nosotros vivimos en este
momento que el 61% de las compras para
navidades se hicieron en nuestras
anteriores del punto de vista real
existen problemas de él en el suministro
evidentemente pero muchos es no
solamente el problema sino simplemente
que la gente está preocupada por la
inflación pensaron que comprarán que iba
a ser mucho más beneficioso en un
momento en eeuu que en el cubit aparente
hacer aparenta estar bajo control y los
mandatos de magasca están desapareciendo
eso incluye a una parte de la población
que siga comprando
en este momento la gente se siente un
poco incómoda con eso pero siguen
comprando ahora jorge las tiendas no
sólo enfrentaban problemas de tipo
logístico sino según tengo entendido
también hay una falta de empleados de
trabajadores así es eeuu está
registrando un récord histórico de
abandono en los trabajos las vacantes en
ese país superan los 10 millones de
puestos mientras que la cifra de
desempleo ronda los 7 millones de
personas pero un dato aún más curioso es
los que abandonan su empleo
voluntariamente son alrededor de 4
millones de personas que dejaron su
trabajo en septiembre según el
departamento de trabajo en los eeuu para
muchos es por los estímulos del gobierno
federal desde marzo de 2020 la fuga se
da principalmente sectores como la
hostelería el comercio y el transporte
nuestro invitado josé guerrero cusumano
nos cuenta qué medidas están tomando
algunos minoristas frente a este dato en
el contexto de la temporada de compras
navideñas escuchamos pero eeuu
lamentablemente la gente advirtió
que iba a tener que comprar cosas más
caras por inflación para comprar cosas
más caras porque evidentemente uno de
los problemas que hay que no beber
suficiente cantidad de trabajadores y
cuando hay trabajadores tienen que
aumentar el sueldo imagínate tú yo soy
un minorista grande o pequeña detallista
como world board uno de los cosas que
estamos viendo es que los precios
aumentan no solamente comunicación sino
por la falta de mano de obra y también
por el salario horario que ha aumentado
lo que hemos visto en estos tres días es
que muchos negocios han cerrado el
jueves realmente eeuu jueves viernes
sábado y domingo y lunes son digamos
importantes pero muchos cadenas
importantes como georgie decidió no
abrir no abrir los juegos por la razón
fundamental es porque evidentemente
primero no tenía la capacidad para
abrirlos y segundo que muchos los
comprobados habían comprado en línea
para jorge en este contexto un gran
problema es la inflación cómo afectará
esto américa latina así es aunque varios
bancos centrales están tomando la
iniciativa de aumentar los tipos de
interés la inflación que sigue en
aumento en eeuu está en cifras récord y
esto tiene su repercusión en países como
argentina chile en méxico que están
mostrando también altos índices de
inflación le preguntamos a nuestro
invitado cómo va a afectar esto en los
próximos meses
y esto nos respondió yo pienso en este
momento en américa la espina esos los
grandes problemas pero vamos a hacer
claro las importaciones a eeuu han
crecido de forma increíble no es que en
los eeuu no esté importando los
diferentes países esté importando de
muchos países latinoamericanos eso
conllevó en beneficios de los países de
américa latina su exportación es eeuu
pero lamentablemente lo que estamos
viendo es que los precios de muchos
productos han aumentado es va a crear
más problemas en américa latina con
respecto a la inflación no hablemos de
situaciones complicadas como argentina o
venezuela pero en otros países también
estamos viendo esa parte en américa
latina estamos viendo una convulsión del
punto de vista político de cambios en
diferentes enfoques con la pública y con
la política de la economía
con todos los problemas asociados con él
cada mes suministro la situación
internacional de los países
desarrollados puede crear más problemas
más inestabilidad inestabilidad en
américa latina interesantísima crónica
de jorge muchísimas gracias a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a continuar
informando hace en france24 sigan con
nosotros
i
[Música]